perry clavon is the director of
executive education at the d school and
an adjunct faculty professor at stanford
school of engineering he's a seasoned
entrepreneur and a product designer but
despite his years of running startups
and corporations perry's true calling is
teaching which is why we love to have
him it's so much fun and then also with
us today we have jeremy utley jeremy is
the director of executive education at
the d school and an adjunct professor at
stanford school of engineering he's also
an outstanding collaborator and teaches
many celebrated courses at stanford
gentlemen it's always a pleasure thank
you for being here with us today and
take it away
awesome thanks so much robin we're
thrilled to get to see everyone today
and we're excited to get started
this question what is design thinking
and why should i care is something that
we hear often at stanford and in the
world and
there's a great thing about design
thinking becoming a popular term which
is that lots of people are curious about
it it's somewhat well known but there's
a downside which is that all of a sudden
it starts to seem special or
inaccessible and that's ironic
for us because the goal of design
thinking is actually to make
the tools and mindsets and ways of
thinking that have helped designers
solve problems available to folks who
don't consider themselves to be
designers or maybe even don't consider
themselves to be creative so very simply
design thinking is a way of coming up
with ideas and seeing whether they're
any good very simply and it's meant to
be not some specialized thing that's
reserved for the chosen few but a set of
tools that can help anyone in any career
in any organization in any role in the
organization
be more effective at solving the
problems you're tackling there whether
those problems look like
introducing new products into the market
or crafting a sales pitch or writing a
subject line to an email or
designing an expense reimbursement
process
we see all of those
as opportunities for design thinking or
for coming up with ideas and learning
whether they're good ideas very simply
just to get started we want to start
with this quote by linus pauling
he said to get a good idea you need a
lot of ideas and that's something that
very few people really appreciate it's
the it's said so simply as only a
two-time nobel prize winning chemist
could say it but it's actually profound
what the research indicates is that the
single most important variable
that affects how good your ideas are
is how many ideas you have
and so while many people are really
focused on coming up with better ideas
the truth is they should be coming up
with more ideas
the way to get to better is actually to
generate more and what we would say is
that design thinking is an exceptional
idea generation methodology to put it
very simply it's a great way to come up
with a volume of ideas and you may be
familiar with a process visualization
that we've used and popularized now
about 10 or 15 years ago through a video
that perry and i made and we released it
on youtube it ended up being viewed gosh
half a million or maybe even a million
times and so this visualization became
very popular probably more popular than
it should have become but it became a
way to describe one way to think about
what designers do which is very simply
they empathize with people they're
trying to design for meaning they try to
get to know them and understand their
feelings and emotions etc then they
define a problem to be solved meaning
they start with that loose understanding
of human beings and say what problem
really matters to those people and then
they idh they generate a bunch of
potential solutions and through series
of prototyping and testing implement
and refine and discover whether their
ideas are any good and the useful thing
about this way of visualizing the
process is it helps us put various tools
that designers might use that we might
recommend that anyone in any role might
consider bringing into their problem
solving process it helps us put them
into buckets
that's been really great the downside of
us using this visualization is a lot of
people have taken design thinking as a
recipe of sorts or a formula of sorts
and they assume that if you you know if
you empty the powder into the bowl and
then you add water and then you beat it
and add an egg that all of a sudden the
cake's gonna come out and so it's not
it's a little bit misleading in so far
as it looks like a linear sequence of
events that has a clear beginning and an
end point it's more a set of mindsets
and so rather than talking about a fixed
process per se what we thought would be
fun to do is actually introduce design
thinking by way of a story because we
have the incredible privilege of getting
to interact with some of the most
innovative individuals and innovative
organizations and even organizations
that don't really seem innovative but
their
employees actually are and they're doing
really cool things we hear a bunch of
great stories and we feel that we're
stewards of those stories we have the
opportunity to showcase how a mindset of
a designer leads to breakthroughs and
leads to realizations and meaningful
impact in human beings lives so we want
to tell quickly the story of our friend
bill pacheco who has a very had a very
illustrious career not only as an
engineering leader at cybex but also as
a director at keurig dr pepper and he
now teaches at trinity college most
importantly though i like to think that
his that the most important organization
he's involved with is perry's nightmare
where he is my doubles partner in tennis
and we like to give very hard time on
the tennis court but perry would you
like to tell the story of bill and his
incredible innovations
yes
so pleasure i just said just to clarify
on the tennis you know front there you
know there's another partner involved i
have a doubles partner logan may be on
the on the group right now logan deans
and i um and uh you know bill gets a lot
of practice these days he and his
brother play all the time so
um anyway and i you know i'm pretty busy
here phil you know so anyway um uh bill
also teaches at bu now as well so boston
university um terrific fellow and it's
such a pleasure one of the great things
about doing the work we do is actually
being able to
um not only talk about alumni of the
programs but use these live examples and
this is something great about the the
programs we put together is it's just
terrific to with linkedin and hear
stories from you all and see how you're
using the tools we teach and it actually
drives a lot of the changes bill for
example
the story i'm about to share with you a
lot of the techniques we use in
prototyping that one step jeremy talked
about have come from the direct work
with bill pacheco
so with that we'll talk about so for
those of you that that the two companies
mentioned
keurig is a coffee company it has those
capsules you may have you stayed in a
hotel or been to you know an airport or
whatever their capsules and they have
this neat technology he he was um did
the product design there for a period of
time with the team and also um earlier
in his career when we met him he was
working at a company called cybex if
you've been on a treadmill machine if
you've been on an elliptical trainer
a stationary bicycle
they're one of the major major suppliers
of equipment like that and chances are
you've been on something actually bill's
designed if you've been to a hotel gym
and actually used anything or for a big
corporate gym
so with that um
i wanted to go and talk a little bit so
we're going to dive a little bit deeper
on so so what we're going to tell is a
story of bill using design thinking as a
way to sort of bring life to the
the steps that um jeremy spoke about and
actually be able to talk to you about
what um
what this looks like in real life okay
and i think that's a big component we're
passionate about this program is
we cover all aspects of design thinking
how you might use it in teams and how
you might use it in a larger larger
organization which is what this story's
about so
here's um cybex cybex is part of a group
of competitors
making a product so we're going to talk
a little bit about
um treadmills so treadmills the thing is
you you hop on top of and you run
and you actually use for um a workout
okay so these are their competitors so
at the time we sort of click into this
this was um
you know about 10 years ago probably
bill was was doing this kind of work um
and
these are the competitors and they're
you know like any company they're sort
of duking it out with these people you
know fighting for market share
and um bill
having had you know training in design
thinking you know
went to a gym and actually um used some
of the techniques of empathy that first
stage is you sort of open up your brain
you you observe you um
maybe inquire and actually talk to folks
asking more open-ended questions but you
leave yourself open to inputs there's
many many different techniques this is a
good example of observation so what bill
did was he took his notebook spent a
while and just stayed and watched
and what he noticed you can tell he's he
shared these pictures you can see these
folks if you just go in close to your
screen you'll see these these amazing
machines that have you know all this
terrific technology and these monitors
all stuff people are holding on to all
the screens and and holding on to things
for dear life you got the sense
there's something more going on here
than
um
i'm aware of you know this is and
something we seek to understand in those
early stages of design thinking is
understanding emotions of the users
not he didn't measure you know um how
long are people on the treadmill how
much do they you know talk about it
wasn't data collection he was really
looking at faces
any what he noticed was the emotion that
was fear what he knows is people were
afraid on these machines and he thought
oh my god that's that's super
interesting to understand and use that
to launch into design thinking and begin
to understand this this um
why they might be feeling fear and take
a sort of a
very open perspective to that so as he
as he talked to folks and and began to
understand
he developed um
some ideas around basically changing
the structure around these products so
keep in mind now he's part of an
organization cybex he has a boss
um and this is a category of product
that the assumption was like many
products
it's it's pretty much set there's a
there's a treadmill you run on there's a
screen you know we've got lots of
competitors there's much better things
you know bill could be working on so he
he sort of
did some quick drawings he sort of said
i'm gonna i'm gonna try to make a
machine that that deals with this aspect
of fear and maybe gives people more
places to hold on to he did some quick
prototypes he did some quick drawings
and like we all do he went to his boss
and he showed it to him and this is the
the note he got back
so those you can't read it says uh he
did this presentation and showed there's
a picture behind this that's that's
hidden but it's a it's a prototype with
these pvc pipes that he sort of built
out quickly which is a technique of
rapid prototyping so he's got this
insight about fear he's done some work
to build something he's got some ideas
and his boss ray says
i'm not a fan of anything in this
presentation so
part of what we see as folks use these
tools and techniques in their
organization is they're new
and part of what uh jeremy actually does
a component with another collaborator
from stanford uh justin farrell about
how you might think about approaching
these organizations
this this was a typical response is you
know
there's nothing to do with treadmills
treadmills are a safe business his boss
wanted him to move on and do something
else
um what he knew was bill knew he had a
great insight he knew the the end user
was afraid he knew there needed to be
changes he could tell there was an
opportunity to sort of pursue this
further
so what he did was he went a step
further and he actually um decided to
take a little bit of extra time you know
not not a huge amount of time but but
built up some really quick prototypes
and began to sort of put these extra
railings on and these these things that
were sort of designed very very
differently to allow people points of
connection to the machine that weren't
about the electronics and weren't about
things that were not intended for that
purpose which is what he saw before
and he did a really interesting thing
that as you get to the design process
you he's he noticed something in empathy
this idea of fear he framed it up and
said i'm gonna build a machine that
addresses these these um points of
stability and these these fear points
and what drives that fear he ideated
came up with a bunch of ideas that was
that presentation he did one step
further he said hey i'm gonna prototype
and test
and that's a great way to validate to
say i'm going to put this out there for
just a little bit and see if
see how the user responds to it so his
his idea was to show his his boss
ultimately some information from that
prototype and test cycle which is what
we espouse
so he went out he put these really rough
prototypes they they look really
polished but he's literally welding
little bars onto them and making him
look good he took him to a hotel gym and
he just
he measured how many people picked the
machine with these new
you know rails and new sort of
ergonomics how many people picked the
existing machine they were just side by
side and he got really good data and
something we espoused with our students
is how do you actually put something out
in the world
and use it to to make sure you validate
it not only validated the problem jerry
talked about there's sort of two things
going on
definitely validated by people picking
one or the other
there's something to the
the aspect of fear they look at that
machine and they say no no they want
this one and then he would talk to
people after using it and see what their
experience was like and get that data
that data allowed him ultimately to put
something into market
so this is a was a success financially
great for the company great outcome
but more so what bill knew was he was
solving a real human need which is at
the core of what we teach with design
thinking is too often we sort of walk
through like accepting an existing
problem statement you know a lot of
business problem statements might be
around how do we increase revenue or how
do we sell more
in the reframe that happened with bill
was he learned hey for for our products
there's this emotion fear
and i'm gonna actually use that to
design and ultimately design a far
better product and it's a great outcome
and a terrific product and if you see it
in the marketplace you'll know all the
backstory of where it came from but i
think a good example of running through
that entire cycle of design
it's an amazing story and there's some
amazing uh comments happening in the
chat too someone mentioned uh let's see
ray said wait you're telling me that he
took action and made a prototype even
after his boss said he didn't like it
and what we'd say is there's really two
really important things there that are
worth unpacking just in response to that
um that question right or that
realization right because a lot of us go
my boss said he hates it
so it's done but design thinking is
really useful and it relates to vivian's
point around the pandemic of trust as
well
design thinking puts us in such close
proximity to the people that we're
designing for or we're trying to
innovate for and it could be a you know
a human being in a gym it could also be
an employee who's the recipient of an hr
policy or an employee who's trying to
file their expense reimbursements or it
could be it could be any one of those
things right so we don't mean to only
limit this way of thinking to new
product introductions but the point is
using a designer's mindset one of the
things we advocate is getting close to
the people whose lives you're hoping to
impact by your work
and what happened for bill is he got
conviction
that people were afraid people felt
unsafe and as he's watching and
interacting with people in gyms that
conviction grew there's there's a need
for for a perception of safety here
that i feel is a really a real human
need a real human pain that deserves to
be met and i think and we've seen that
countless times with many individuals
inside organizations the senior
management will say you know to our
friend doug deeds who pioneered an
incredible innovation at ge with a
pediatric device that the senior
leadership at the time said there's very
few pediatric wards in the united states
don't waste your time on this but just
like bill
doug had engaged with the people whose
lives he was trying to improve with
design
and he felt their pain strongly enough
to ignore what his bosses said
effectively and one of the amazing
things about design is all of a sudden
you can quickly become the resident
expert in the people's lives who you're
hoping to transform with your work
efforts and so that's the first thing
the second thing is and i think it's
also related to ray's question about
wait bill just pushed through even
though his boss said no
what he realized is his boss is reacting
to an idea
but he has no information he doesn't
understand there's no way to
contextualize the idea other than
according to his own past history
and what bill realized what's really
magical is part of the design mindset is
saying
really quickly i can actually create
data you know our organizations love
data and we think about looking up data
and looking up research reports but what
designers are doing or what individuals
who don't consider themselves creative
or designers before
but who are using these tools that's who
we're calling designers what designers
do is they're actually finding clever
ways to create new data sets
which help them make better decisions
and as perry mentioned when bill put the
couple of you know prototype units
inside of a hotel he was able to watch
people vote with their feet
and so even though ray's got 65 patents
in the space and even though he thinks
it's a bad idea he can't deny the fact
that when 30 people walked into the gym
28 of them chose this machine
why did they choose it that really
validated the sense of fear that bill
had picked up on right and so it's that
kind of enlightened trial and error that
we're advocating where you're really
deeply connecting with the people whose
lives are hoping to change
and then you're willing humbly to be
learning whether you've got it right or
not and if bill had implemented it and
it didn't go well i think he would have
given up the hunt or he would have found
a different way to go about trying to
convey a sense of safety but the point
is not insubordination the point is
thoughtful care about how do we impact
the people whose lives we are trying to
impact and how can we help stimulate our
own thinking as we said at the beginning
with this linus pauling quote
we need a lot of ideas
and
there's some research that indicates
that the average corporate brainstorm
generates two ideas just two
and so what design thinking does is it
helps
teams overcome that tendency to settle
very very quickly
but we mentioned before that this this
way that we've been describing the
design process is a little bit outdated
and so we thought would be fun to do
before we dive into some more of these
questions here and perry maybe you can
be looking at the questions and seeing
if there's anything that we want to
start with but we thought it'd be useful
to say how we think about describing the
process now if it's not these five
colorful hexagons how do we describe it
now and what we'd say is very simply
design thinking is made in advance on
conventional problem solving
where conventional problem solving
basically is this a boss says implement
this solution they hand you a grain of
sand they hand you an ideopost it do
this right that's it and what design
thinking said it makes two meaningful
advances the first advance that we
advocate is we say hang on before we
converge on one solution let's diverge
and let's generate as many
possible ideas or ways to solve the
problem that's been given as possible
so the first step is diverge before we
come verbs right and that's an enormous
advance over implement this solution the
other significant advance that we have
made in the d-school is that we've said
actually let's recognize that there's
two pieces to any problem-solving
endeavor
and we think a lot about problem-solving
but let's stop for a second let's talk
about problem finding
because really implicit to any solution
we're trying to implement is a problem
that we think we want to solve and what
designers
have become very adept at
is being as clear about the problem
they're trying to solve
as they are about the solution that
they're advocating and just like with
the solution it's also an opportunity
that we diverge we generate lots of
potential problems and ways of thinking
about the problem or framing as we might
say before we converge and it's useful
to think that there's these two
discrete outputs to a design effort
because a lot of times people just think
about the answer and what we would say
is the question is every bit as
important john dewey the famous american
educational reformer said a problem well
put is half solved and so a lot of the
efforts that we spend in the design
practice and that you might spend if
you're doing finance or hr or product
development or marketing or content
strategy a lot of your time is actually
spent framing a problem worth solving
before you ever even undertake the tools
to think about how you solve it the goal
ultimately is to get this high degree of
alignment where you have a high degree
of confidence that the problem that
you've identified and the solution
you've imagined overlap and everybody's
you know goal
is that these things would overlap
perfectly it rarely happens that way in
the beginning more often than not
there's kind of a misfit and there's not
a uh
there's not quite the right way to think
about it and so teams
that get good at design are constantly
assessing both of the of these things
the problem that they've articulated and
the solutions they've imagined and
they're assessing their fit
and
the way they assess their fit is by
being uh
by being clear about not only what
they're working on meaning right now we
focus on the problem or we focus on the
solution but also how they're working
meaning are we are we generating options
are we making decisions so if you think
about those that kind of that two by two
there are four discrete buckets
that we could draw from at any time to
help us think about how we might advance
our thinking and when we talk about
process now a lot of times we talk in
terms of these buckets because it's a
little bit more useful it's a little bit
less prescriptive it's a little bit less
sequential and it helps us capture the
goal
is for any team to be able to be
fluent about what kind of activity do i
need to undertake right now to continue
to advance
my learning about the problem we're
trying to solve or the way that we're
trying to solve it and so ultimately
we aren't looking for robots or
automatons who can perfectly recite
chapter and verse on the correct
sequence of events so much as
individuals who have a fluency and a
confidence and a capability around self
navigating what am i working on right
now how should i be working and what
tools would be appropriate for me to
draw upon next that's how we like to
think about process here with that i'll
stop and maybe perry have you seen a
couple questions that we want to dive
into
absolutely
so there's um
so rick white uh in the middle of the
list made a great comment and um i
wanted to go back to it so it's number
if yours are numbered it's number 33.
um but it's a it's a great comment
jeremy that sort of
punctuates something you've been saying
and i think he he he wrote it better
than you said it just gotta call it out
there you got it i love it he said um
businesses seem to keep us focused on
the product
parentheses output
it seems like you are saying that
creative process needs more inputs
and i would say
that's a that's i wish that we had you
know like put that at the at the
beginning as like almost like a tenant
for designers which i very much agree is
you're mindful of inputs
so in the story about bill he was
mindful about inputs he was mindful
about going out and getting more content
he was sort of able to say
you know if i think about treadmills or
think about the next project i'm going
to work on have i spent some time in a
gym and just observed have i spent some
time do i have some ideas about how
people are feeling
on some of that and he may have gone
there on a day when
he noticed somebody on the stationary
bicycle to be a different story about a
stationary bicycle but he was mindful
i need i need some input
and he's as an individual i know him to
be that way now he's mindful about his
inputs and mindful about am i spending
time you know we give one actually one
of the components of the class is about
daily practice
and about techniques for you as an
individual to build being mindful about
inputs into your practice but designers
are seeking inputs
to frame up interesting new questions
but bill found a really interesting
problem because he was mindful of inputs
and then later on when he said hey you
know what my what my maybe my boss needs
is some other input to this project
which is some data
some some information from testing to
see what happens
um and then there was a question i
wanted to sort of tie in with this which
that was was um
fascinating so jonathan
laplante um number three i'm glad you
pointed that one out hoping for them too
i've tried the design thinking
brainstorming method with a few business
partners and our issue is usually that
we end up with a list of hundreds of
ideas which is great work awesome
um
some of them really good
but then we go back to the opportunity
we had before the design thinking
brainstorming session
sadly i find business partners will fall
back on whatever seems like it is the
easiest path
what they know and don't want to so it
goes on but but the idea is you're
you're selecting
when you use this process
so
bill sort of in a way that story we we
tell the magical story of persevering
and making it through that and um you
know getting to a very interesting
outcome
what i love jonathan is the honesty so
thank you for the comment that
one thing that's hard is you know so
many of the problems you know we face
and i'm sure all of you face in your
personal life and your professional life
sort of that the problem you know
presupposes this path and
you know i think we come in we say oh
design thinking you know wander around
and look at these things and dream up a
new problem and you know the reality is
i love john that well that's super fun
and we did that and we generally watched
your idea but then you come back in and
it's we got to get stuff done here we're
done with the design part you know we've
got to select something got to move
forward with something that that for
sure solves this problem and we'd say
the the one of the things we espouse and
sort of you if you think about design
thinking it's largely
we're finding a problem and then we're
we're solving that problem is this
there's two halves of the diagram or or
on the screen right now the two halves
of what's happening there
you know we would say on the on the um
the product side on the on the
production side we espouse really really
rapid prototyping techniques so taking
an attitude of how can i spend
just a little bit longer or even shorten
if you're coming up with hundreds of
ideas hundreds of ideas john then i
would say shorten your brainstorming
time and leave time right then and there
to build some of the ideas to make some
really rough prototypes to
to keep alive some of the wilder ideas
and say we're going to suspend this
this sort of decision making and we're
just going to build out a couple of
these and make them real and we teach
these
very very fast and simple low resolution
prototyping techniques
and that's a fabulous skill to go
through life with is how do i build a
quick prototype you know this is
something you know robin who somebody
was asking what was the name of the
person robin's been amazing in building
the content of the programs that's been
the approach we've taken to to building
the courses is how do we do something
really really quick to jeremy's point
put it up on youtube get some feedback
and then do another one that's
completely different and that's the way
we approach it is the question i would
be asking jonathan is how do i do
you know 10 prototypes and do it so
quickly and so efficiently that that we
can do that in minutes and get some
concepts to be real so we can actually
have some data to evaluate because i
think the thing is missing is you can
select an idea from that list that's
doable for the business but you you if
you had a chance to compare it to some
of the other ideas a little bit as you
went further you might have some data to
move forward with
yeah the other thing i would say there
just on that question
jonathan is
if you don't have the opportunity to um
if you don't have the opportunity to
create something in the middle of the
interaction
then then another great thing you can do
is you can at least schedule time for
creating something later we call that
writing a love note to your future self
because a lot of times you realize we've
got potential here but we and we're out
of time we're about to rush to other
meetings
if if there's no ownership and there's
no sense of uh when the follow-up is
then there's not going to be a new
conversation
unless there's new information and a lot
of times folks teams tend to kick these
decisions down the road or like you said
just default to what we already decided
we wanted to do
and the only way to change that is if
someone you know at amazon they call
them single threaded ownership or single
threaded leaders someone takes
responsibility for it so a great a great
tactic is as a leader say who's going to
take this and run with us in the next
week when we meet next week what are we
what are we asking about are we asking
about you know uh click-through rates
open rates or like what what do we want
to know about and then commission
someone to actually create that data and
then the other thing they'd say is what
are they going to stop doing
you can't give somebody something new
without also kind of
drawing back some level of
responsibility so which two or three
standing meetings do they not need to
attend in the next week so that they can
create that data a lot of times it's
actually it's almost like you know i've
worked in india for a while and there's
what's known in india as the last mile
problem it's like it's really difficult
to penetrate to the last mile in rural
areas and that's where the majority of
the population is this is a last mile
problem when it comes to
operationalizing innovation
ownership
what's the next step what's the outcome
and a lot of times with nebulous new
ideas
it's kind of nobody's job and if you
allow it to be nobody's job leaving a
meeting you shouldn't be surprised that
nobody does anything right so to flip
that script you have to actually assign
the work and use it's go with enthusiasm
who's stoked on it who really wants to
see who really wants to explore great
you're going to own it and we're so
excited to see the data next week in our
next team meeting
yeah the other one so there's a there's
a bunch in here that follow up so ray a
quick a quick question that i think
follows up on that what method do you
suggest to sort out a lot of ideas so
the practical thing we we actually teach
is is being mindful about selection
process
so as you move from ideation you're
generating lots and lots of ideas
meaning you've you've found that that
emotional insight as bill did he framed
up a unique challenge how do i make uh
people not fearful of their experience
on exercise equipment if you generated a
lot of ideas then you might select you
might you might come up with more
interesting selection criteria you know
recently um another associative of ours
uh dr catherine segovia who we teach
with a lot who's actually in the
program here she runs the practice
component um
we've been working with this medical
company and we've been
we've been talking to them a lot they're
generating all kinds of new ideas about
this this really interesting um medical
product i can't go to details on it
because it's all sort of super secret
and we've talked a lot about this topic
of how do you select ideas you know one
selection criteria if you want to go you
know back and talk about
um you know rick and jonathan a little
bit they you might just default to a
selection criteria what's within our
budget what can we do
we've talked about being more mindful of
selecting ideas you know what could
dazzle you know the customer
what what could make the custom in
billscape what would make the customer
feel incredibly safe
what would make the customer feel like
they could start you know immediately on
this exercise device those might be
selection criteria to sort through ideas
and there's no
exact selection criteria meaning what
what jeremy and i do a lot in classes is
we might take a group of ideas
and select with one selection criteria
we might select with the the you know
what can we what can we what do we think
we could do on a tight budget great
there are a couple ideas that come to
mind then we might take you know a
different color you know um dot or a
different color post-it and sort of put
tabs on other ones we might select which
one would most likely delight the
customer
which one would actually uh deliver a
unique experience versus our competitors
but the point is
we're slicing and dicing ideas with
multiple selection criteria and i think
too often we move as
these these folks talked about in those
quite early questions with a singular
one like we've got to have a list you
know 100 this is the best this is this
is what we're going to start with and
what we espouse is mix it up try
different selection criteria it's almost
like you
you get a mosaic sometimes it looks like
a heat map where we're selecting with so
many different criteria and you've got
all these different colors to be
different things on a group of post-its
um that you can actually sort of see
potentially
multiple aspects of solutions and come
up with a um this is maybe a something
we we can talk about in the in another
question as well jeremy is this idea of
building a portfolio that i think
another thing designers do is they think
about having a portfolio of solutions
not
going to that single solution early on
but saying how about i build a group of
solutions how many select a bunch of
different ideas based on different
selection criteria it leaves my options
open and it allows me to to have
different prototypes out there
generating comparative data
and and helping me see the path forward
out of vagueness to clarity and that's
what we
always espouse we have a we have a class
called d leadership and i think at
different times the the teams are
working on
two or three problem statements each was
two or three prototypes so that it gives
them it's a lot of work and a lot of
confusion
sometimes and it gives them a lot of
clarity as to a direction forward if you
will that this idea of building multiple
solutions and the same thing with having
multiple selection criteria
i wanted to um i wanted to go to ava de
breva's uh i hope i'm saying that right
ava um question
or comment she said customers don't know
what they want you can go ahead and ask
them right
uh as henry ford said if i ask my
customers what they wanted they would
have said a faster horse she uses these
examples do you need amazon prime do you
need facebook do you need airbnb so
leaving them to come up with their needs
based on the problems they have doesn't
seem like the most efficient approach
and ava if whatever you're doing for
your employment doesn't work out please
come and join our team at stanford
because we couldn't agree more um there
is we are not human-centered design is
not customer-led design it's not uh it's
not
taking instructions from the customer
far from it and you have to be careful
to craft uh experiments really is what
we would say it's an experimental
mindset that give you highly credible
data and in another one of our sessions
we you may have seen this if you've seen
many of our webinars but it's worth just
repeating very briefly
just taking as this as a case study
january 2016 the executive team of
westfield mall in downtown san francisco
is having a emergency meeting because
tenants on their fourth floor moving out
of the fourth floor rents are falling
and they don't understand what to do
they've got
a problem with foot traffic tenants keep
saying not enough people are coming up
here and despite the beautiful frescoes
and panoramic views of the city
it's not enough to drive foot traffic to
the fourth floor and actually forestall
the plummet of rent
and so they've got a crisis on their
hands they had a quick brainstorm one of
the ideas that came out of the
brainstorm was we should put a beer
garden on the fourth floor wouldn't that
be amazing you know same thing about
startup founders coming up like greek
gods onto mount olympus and drinking
ambrosia it'd be wonderful
so
thankfully they
thought we should at least
ask people if they like this idea
they went down to the to the lobby to
the first floor to the food court if we
built a beer garden on the fourth floor
gorgeous views would you come
something like 85 percent of people said
yes
and so ava to your chagrin i'm sure they
spent quite a bit of money to build out
this beer garden and it won't surprise
you i know ava to to realize that months
later it was a colossal uh mishap they
hardly attracted any more foot traffic
to the fourth floor rents continued to
fall
uh
tenants continued to move out and they
were left scratching their heads saying
what did we do wrong right
we came up we brainstormed we came up
with ideas we asked people what they
wanted and they brought us in to be a
part of that post-mortem so to speak and
one of the things that became clear is
they had this great data right they
talked to a thousand people 850 of them
said yes if you build it will come and
what we challenged them on was it's it
may be data but not all data is created
equal and you ask people what they like
you know is it i mean i've been the
puppy dog intern before myself saying
mister would you sign up for a magazine
put me down for a nickel buddy you know
and people say yes but it's not really
an indication of what they'll do
and we worked with the team as they
tried to solve the problem in the future
saying
how do we create environments and
experiences and offers that yield more
highly credible data you know one of the
simplest ideas that came out of this
discussion
you can hire an hourly worker put them
at the top of the fourth floor escalator
outside of the you know elevator bank
put a bunch of curtains up right not do
any of the actual remodeling work or
renovation work give the intern you know
a pitcher a beer and a cactus so it's a
beer garden technically
and then put signs all over the mall
saying visit our beer garden on the
fourth floor it's like any time somebody
comes up in turn form a beer you know
great it's free
where's the where's the garden while
we're still working on it but we're so
glad you're here right really quickly
you know if the intern with his third
hand or her third hand is just kind of
clicking
how many people are coming up really
quickly they realized that that value
proposition wasn't driving foot traffic
and the big question is when people
become aware of an opportunity do they
hit the fourth floor button on the
elevator
and that's what they should have been
measuring and because they said if we
did it would you come they gave people
an opportunity to lie to them
customers will lie to you not because
they're malicious but because one they
can't imagine the truth and two
i don't want to tell the poor puppy dog
intern with the clipboard no it just
doesn't feel good right so you have to
you have to design
um interactions that give you more
highly credible data than survey
information so to all that say just
wanted to second what uh dr ava de brova
professor emeritus mentioned
don't ask people what they want we
totally agree
yeah and then you you've also answered i
think a couple other questions jeremy
somebody asked is there could you give
an example of design thinking that
doesn't involve um engineering
um i think it was a jessica and then
which is a great so now you get an
example that involves beer drinking
and i'd say somebody else um asked i
think it was valerie one of your
questions about um
hey is it do you have to use this for a
product and can you use it for a process
and absolutely you can use it for a
process i think that sometimes as
examples uh we pick something that's
like oh this is this is clever and a
product tends to you know go and we can
sort of tell a quick story and there's
an output there's a thing that it all
goes into um process we have we have
amazing alumni stories i remember one
that comes to mind was a executive one
of our programs and design thinking that
that uh
went uh back to american express and
redesigned you know the entire process
for for helping folks to get stuck in a
in a big weather event you notice that
hey one of the things that happens is
all of our processes sort of break down
in these big events like the recent one
hurricane i did people are delayed stuck
in airports we don't have new solutions
and there's tech different techniques
for it um we espouse a lot of um
improvisational activities so if we're
thinking about a product you know we you
know valerie you and i are thinking
about hey we have a different idea for a
process what if somebody called in and
then they got this and then this
happened we might act it out i might act
like the customer and you might act like
the process sounds weird but i come in
and say hey i'm perry i'm stuck in the
airport and then you would you would
respond you'd respond you know we run
through a scenario together that would
be one prototype then we try a different
one and we might even do that with um
then bringing in a actual outside user
and um act as if it exists and run
somebody through it with the minimum
effort to sort of build anything
and a lot of times this results in um
sort of multiple flow charts so we might
have a flow chart of one process and a
flowchart of another and a flowchart of
another and we we would sort of be able
to compare which ones are faster which
ones um you know result in um outcomes
that are favorable which ones create new
questions yeah we could we could again
sort of look at those and evaluate them
but absolutely um
process
is is a largely actually if i think
about so many of the student projects
now we deal with process is becoming
much more actually what we we use it for
if i think about um
many many of the projects going on in
classes at stanford
i'm just trying to uh to answer a bunch
of questions
as much as i can in the chat here looks
like one link we shared at one point
was broken i'm trying to go in and tell
people that it's fixed yeah and i don't
recall any questions somebody else was
asking a little bit about um how to get
teams to do this and how do you approach
teams
and um i would say one of the things i'm
scanning for the person's name as i look
somewhere else here but um
um
anyway so if you could find jeremy it
was earlier on but in terms of
application of teams i think one of the
um the
big ideas with david kelly and starting
the design school um
is that
students going through our programs have
a consistent approach
and i think the biggest thing to to
bringing this into an organization
is we we see a lot of times teams have
trouble when
you know one person's ideating while the
next person's trying to build a
prototype or somebody's trying to make a
decision and converge while the other
person to jeremy's point is diverging
and coming up with new ideas
and i think the
teaching a consistent process to teams
if there's any sort of
amazing you know insight to what the d
school has done at stanford is it's
given language to students to to have
consistent process
and it's even a few of our a couple
students even commenting here chris i
see on there like on the questions
um
so but i think they could comment as as
well if if you ever talk to them is like
it's really cool to have a consistent
understanding because chris for example
is a student on there is asking a
question he comes to a session on
wednesday mornings for this class we do
and he might be talking to an mba
student or a different student or
something but they have a consistent
understanding of an approach and
consistent language around it so they
can even comment on each other's work
and dive in and help each other
and for teams working that consistent
understanding of a process is amazingly
helpful particularly think about the
kind of work we're working on it's
uncertain work design is uncertain work
so so in a way it it amplifies a lot of
emotion it amplifies a lot of the the
challenges with working with teams
and consistency of understanding we're
doing we're ideating right now we're
generating ideas we'll make a decision
at the end of that we'll then prototype
and test we'll then evaluate the data
from testing it gives um teams the
ability to work effectively with a
consistent approach to problem solving
if there's one sort of tenant
with this is we have seen it really
really effective if a team has a
consistent approach to a problem solving
technique
we have time for more questions you
think perry or should we try to wrap or
what do you what do you think
i'm going to push these i just wanted to
call it we had we had two folks that um
asked questions that we wanted to
definitely cover
um
marty these are people that submitted um
early questions uh marty i thought this
question was great about a
water utilities so they're dealing and
she's she's in water utilities
um
and the question was how could i develop
a way for people to use data
collaboratively with the goal for them
to adopt and embrace a new way to
discommune community old practice so
she's trying to design i i take this and
i say wow uh marty is such an
interesting problem and i'm glad because
it follows on the heels of that that
answer like hey design can be used for
process this is a process and i think
what's what's interesting is you should
approach this as
um you know do some of the work that
david did i would say design thinking
101 is go out and ask your peers you
know ask them what kind of challenges
they're having getting to you know
decisions in the organization what kind
of challenges they're having with
people's understanding of data what kind
of challenges they're having how they're
feeling about results you'll gain some
insights and then frame up the your
effort i think is to design a new
process inside of the company it's a
great example sort of a more advanced
example which i love we're covering
um use the input from emotion frame up a
different challenge
and then actively try try running a
meeting differently jeremy had mentioned
this that a lot of times we some of the
output we get is you know how do i run
this meeting differently and that
meeting is a chance to design and it's a
thing that can be designed just like um
you know the treadmill device
so
um approach it as how do i gather more
input you know i think you're you're i
can tell a frustration i want to change
this old practice we'll gather input
from employees understand their
emotional needs understand the
challenges they're having
build some problem statements around
that and then try some prototyping
and then the other one i wanted to cover
do you want to cover this one jeremy
that's such a interesting
go ahead
okay
or nair from glendale this is an
interesting product i could use it for
my covet times it's a
sensorized shoe insole that measures
your weight
so
jeremy at different times of cover
wait let's be honest jeremy you've had
some problems with donuts both of us at
different times i've had a few
excursions that's true yeah yeah um
so uh we want to provide one stress-free
metric which will provide happiness and
holistic feedback on how to increase
activity and improve wellness
should it be binary am i doing good or
not or should it be a more detailed
report
um
with all of the metrics so the there um
i have no idea and i think you're asking
this because it's the end seem to have
no idea and the answer is
i would this would be a fabulous thing
the previous project as well as
fabulous projects for design thinking
it's like i think it'd be so interesting
to understand
not about the metric
there
that's not if you focus focus on what's
the metric what's metric but i think
what's so interesting is what do people
want to know about their health i mean
perry's joking about donuts but there's
actually something i i would love to
interview on this and be interviewed
about what are my needs what what are my
concerns about my health on a daily
basis particularly in this in the world
we're living in now where i'm standing
in the same
you know square meter year for the whole
day
you know how am i feeling about my
health what what are what are um some
potential you know things tell me about
the lab man ask a question tell me about
the last time you thought about your
health while you're standing in front of
the screen
and how do you address it tell me that
story you could do all kinds of
really fun interviews and get some
insights and get some challenges and
then potentially deliver different types
of information prototypes so different
types of answers on metrics and
information to these individuals and get
a sense of how they react to them and i
wouldn't approach this as the one thing
and the question i think is interesting
to call out is
looking for an answer i think early on i
would look for how do i create a
portfolio of potential dashboards of
information how do i create dozens that
i could show users that might be a
mindset to take on the very beginning
that i'm not going to get to that answer
i'm going to get to a a bunch of
different potential creative answers put
them in front of users and i'm going to
continue to learn and eventually get to
a subset that we want to put out as
product
so that jeremy i think we have just a
couple minutes to cover
that last bit of content
yeah i would say the one thing that i
would mention just before we've got a
couple of slides we wanted to wrap with
but one thing that i wanted to mention
is it's
it's very important to realize
conventional wisdom is often right and
sometimes wrong
and in many organizations like you saw
it with ray right there is a
conventional paradigm you know 1905 is
known as the miracle year i don't know
if you're aware of this but it's when
einstein wrote
his groundbreaking works on relativity
what's interesting is in 1900 just five
years earlier
lord kelvin had reported to the british
association for the advancement of
science
there is nothing new to be discovered in
physics now all that remains is more and
more precise measurement
and he was the world authority in
physics right which is to say what
even the experts even world renowned
experts are sometimes wrong
and it takes a little bit of naivete it
takes a little bit of fresh perspective
it takes a big bit of a beginner's
mindset to challenge convention
and
and you shouldn't expect to challenge
conviction convention and not experience
resistance there's a reason it's
convention conventional wisdom is
usually right
but challenging it oftentimes leads to
unexpected breakthroughs we've seen it
across industries from arts to science
to uh to law even
challenging conventions is a really
great way to do it but don't expect to
be
your resistance free path there will be
resistance there
just as we wrap one of the things
hopefully that you identified in all of
our answers to these questions
is we don't have the answers
we are not answer guys we are approach
guys and design thinking itself isn't an
answer it's an approach and what we
would say is
be thoughtful about your approach and we
can coach individuals on the approach
but i love like nera's question who
knows if it should be binary right but
you know what she what what perry
basically advised her is define the
outcome variable meaning what are you
hoping somebody does
check back again tomorrow
share on social media whatever it is
right define the outcome variable and
then do both of those things and see
which one impacts your outcome variable
in the most desirable way wow when i
make it binary all of a sudden people's
engagement goes through the roof right
or
when i give a detailed report it does
right but we're advocating an approach
and the approach that we advocate is one
where we're mindful of the questions
that are driving our action a lot of
people talk about the miracle year terry
just you know it's all the miracle year
um but the uh i'm trying to watch chat
and talk at the same time it's i
wouldn't recommend it i'm like a a cow
that has multiple stomachs
except with my brain
and i'm randomly thinking of metaphors
while doing this my point is
design thinking isn't isn't only action
a lot of people think about design
thinking they hear bias towards action
and it could just be this frivolous
random you know set of active flurry of
activity
what we advocate is thoughtful
deliberate action where we just where we
know we're not going to know the answer
until we act so action is a must
but what action we take is informed by
thoughtful inquiry and we call it
inquiry driven design and i'll just
finish by saying if you think about how
what's the question
how do i know which bucket to draw from
you've got to be able to answer a couple
of questions one is what's our big
unknown and i've got this here
unfortunately the the uh on 24 someone
mentioned on 24 needs to be redesigned
that's funny um but it's a simple wheel
where we can say okay what's my big
unknown
do i not know the problem i'm trying to
solve okay good or do i not know you
know the answer to the problem i've
identified right so what's our big
unknown and then what kind of thinking
is going to help us make progress do we
need to be so once i say okay i'm on the
blue right now do i need to be j uh you
know
uh making decisions or do i need to be
generating options right and if i say i
need to be making decisions great then
where do i need to be drawing tools from
well i should probably be drawing tools
from that converge on the solution
bucket oh
i know these several tools to converge
on solutions here's what's kind of
behind those sliders there but
are these questions basically but when
we talk about
the process of design we're not just
talking about action and we're not just
talking about a sequence or a
prescription or a recipe we're talking
about a thoughtful
inquiry-led
approach to taking action in order to
address uncertainty both on the
solutions that we're imagining side and
also on the problems we are attempting
to solve aside so this is how we think
about process hopefully this has been a
demystifying experience for you
our goal is to make these tools and
these mindsets accessible
to
somebody in product development and
somebody in hr and somebody in
accounting
wherever it is we believe that we can
bring more rigor more fun and better
problem solving to whatever role you
might play in your organization whatever
industry your organization might be in
and we hope the tools we've shared today
just wet your appetite a little bit
there's no way to go in deeply into the
tools but that's what the online
programs are for there's an amazing set
of resources and tools in these programs
and we're excited to see how you use
them not only to impact your work but
also to change your life and to change
the world we wish you all the best of
luck
and jeremy and your rap you didn't lose
anybody 682 of you are still here
so anyway awesome and we me when we say
we we are passionate about these tools
being out there and you using them and
we love hearing from you with hard
questions or you know um these amazing
some people are sharing if you can see
all the questions sharing how they view
some of these tools and we just find
that fascinating and it keeps us hard at
work so thank you and thank all of you
for the amazing uh questions we love it
i wish we could get to all of them we
have done our best um but thank you so
much
perry and jeremy that was great and
everyone who's here with us today the
engagement was just
so fabulous it really felt like a
personal one-on-one conversation and i
just really love that dynamic also when
you guys submit questions or you know
expand on something that gives us great
insight about where we need to go next
so the content that we can produce
and you know
answer these um so that was really
helpful and thanks so much for joining
us today and we're going to sign off
from stanford thanks perry thanks jeremy
thank you
have a great day everybody
you